merci d'être avec nous Cédric et nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure élu du Territoire de Belfort
donc du groupe les républicains
vice-présidents de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées et pendant cette
demi-heure on va évidemment revenir sur
ces 1 an de guerre en Ukraine d'abord
qu'est-ce qui vous marque le plus au
bout de ces 1 an de conflits
le plus c'est cette guerre
qui finalement dans bien des domaines je
pense comparable à ce qui s'est passé
pour la première guerre mondiale avec
une guerre qui est en train de
s'enterrer une guerre de tranchées
finalement on revient au fait dire aux
fondamentaux de la guerre ou alors qu'on
pensait que les guerres seraient
technologiques aujourd'hui finalement
elle reste éminemment humaine d'un point
de vue en tout cas des pertes et
ce qui est ce qui me marque beaucoup
c'est évidemment cette ce bouleversement
de l'ordre mondial qui est en train de
se mettre en place et dont on a encore
pas vu toutes les conséquences de bien
étendue tout à l'heure avec Julien
Bonnefoy qui sera avec nous depuis
Clermont-Ferrand pour vous interroger
sur ce sujet mais on va évidemment
parler de la question militaire de la
question des armes puisque vous avez
particulièrement travaillé sur ce sujet
est-ce que la France est à la traîne en
matière de livraison d'armes à l'Ukraine
écoutez j'ai coutume de dire que la plus
belle fille du monde ne peut donner que
ce qu'elle a et que aujourd'hui compte
tenu du modèle d'armée que nous avons
construit depuis 20 30 ans peut-être
plus qui était modèle d'armée qui avait
vocation à être un modèle
expéditionnaire sur des guerres choisies
et pas sur des guerres subies il est
bien évident que notre modèle a été
constitué avec ce que certains
expliquent un modèle assez
échantillonnaire c'est-à-dire une armée
parfaitement aguerrie
compétente dotée de matériel qui sont
parfois du matériel
très très technologique mais en quantité
malheureusement insuffisante en tout cas
suffisante pour les pour les opérations
que nous menions jusqu'à présent mais
depuis 24 février dernier le monde a
changé malheureusement et il faut que
maintenant l'armée française s'adapte et
reprennent en tout cas
de la masse et du volume de de en termes
de d'armes et de munitions
on va évidemment parler des conséquences
c'est l'objet de votre rapport des
conséquences de ce qu'on livre sur
l'armée française mais sur ce qu'on doit
livrer à l'Ukraine Sébastien Lecornu a
annoncé des livraisons de chats pour la
fin de la semaine c'est-à-dire là en ce
moment est-ce qu'on a pas trop tardé à
livrer ses chars
écoutez l'armée française dispose de
deux environ 220 chars sur les papiers
donc pas forcément il y a de
fonctionnement
et donc c'est compliqué de d'arriver à
constituer une une j'allais dire un des
bataillons de chars qui soient cohérent
quand on a d'un côté des challengers de
l'autre côté de léopards et ensuite des
Leclercs donc je pense qu'il faut
vraiment qu'il y ait une une entente
européenne ou occidentale en tout cas
sur le type de matériel qui sera livré
de manière à ce que les ukrainiens et le
matériel le plus efficient le plus
efficace c'est qu'il leur permettra de
de tenir en tout cas ce qu'on appelle le
MCO le maintien en conditions
opérationnel du matériel de manière
efficace parce que si vous avez une
multitude de matériel c'est compliqué
c'est les charges sont du matériel
fragiles qui nécessitent beaucoup
d'entretien et de changement de pièces
et donc il faut qu'on ait quelque chose
qui soit cohérent et le fait que l'Union
européenne c'est suffisamment concerté
pour faire des envois cohérents à
l'Ukraine des leçons qu'on doit tirer de
cette guerre en Ukraine c'est aussi la
capacité de l'Union européenne à
travailler même si il y a des choses qui
peuvent être critiquable à travailler de
concert et je pense que c'est absolument
pas ce que le Vladimir Poutine attendait
et on l'a vu au lendemain de la du
déclenchement de la guerre il y a pile
un an l'Union européenne l'OTAN se sont
mobilisés l'ont fait de manière assez
assez remarquable
entendre je ne sais pas en tout cas il y
a des tiraillements qui sont qui sont
dommageables mais ce que ce que cette
guerre ce que cette guerre nous apprend
aussi c'est qu'il faut que nous ayons le
matériel qui soit interopérable qui
puisse être en tout cas utilisés par
tout un chacun et donc c'est à ce à quoi
il faut qu'on travaille mais pour avoir
du matériel interopéra du matériel qui
soit un peu j'allais dire
identique dans chaque pays il faut que
nous arrivions à travailler en
partenariat avec nos avec nos voisins et
amis européens ce qui est
particulièrement compliqué je pense que
cette guerre en Ukraine elle rebat les
cartes quand je disais tout à l'heure
que ce qui me marquait c'était le
bouleversement de l'ordre mondial c'est
aussi versement de l'ordre économique
mondial et aujourd'hui cette guerre en
Ukraine et le développement de l'OTAN en
tout cas le réveil le temps au niveau au
niveau
d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
militaire chez nous c'est aussi
malheureusement la conséquence ça va
être aussi l'arrivée des américains avec
avec leur matériel quand les Américains
promettent au pays qui donneront des
léopards ou des chars d'autres n'importe
quel char à l'Ukraine de remplacer ses
jardins
il faut bien comprendre que la logique
elle est aussi économique derrière c'est
à dire que c'est c'est mettre un coin
significatif dans le projet de char du
futur que les Allemands et les Français
sont en train de mettre en oeuvre parce
que demain
les gens qui auront des Abrahams à
choisiront d'acheter des Abrahams plutôt
que des chars
franco-allemand et que les États-Unis
profitent de cette guerre pour imposer
son industrie militaire à l'Europe je
suis membre de l'Assemblée parlementaire
de l'OTAN j'ai été rapporté en général
de la commission sécurité défense et
j'ai toujours considéré même si je pense
fondamentalement que le temps est
capital j'ai toujours pensé que le temps
était aussi un outil de domination
économique des États-Unis sur l'Europe
et une manière pour eux en tout cas
d'imposer leur industrie de la défense
en Europe on le voit dans les pays de
l'Est on le voit voilà la réassurance
aujourd'hui de l'Europe les Européens
hors la France la doivent et la devront
et c'est ce qu'ils essaient en tout cas
de dire de plus en plus aux Américains
on va continuer à parler des
conséquences des livraisons d'armes sur
entamée mais un dernier mot sur ce qu'on
lit parce que ou sur ce qu'on ne livre
pas à plus précisément puisqu'elle
manuel Macron reste très flou sur les
livraisons d'avions il dit que rien
n'était exclu est-ce que la position
française vous semble compréhensible
moi je pense qu'il faut pas non plus en
faire trop de publicité je pense qu'un
moment donné ce genre de choses qui a
vocation quand même largement à exciter
en tout cas les Russes doit rester
discret je pense qu'on en fait un peu
trop et que on doit donner l'information
je pense que la France ce sont les pays
non les pays du monde de l'Union
européenne en général je pense que les
parlements doivent devraient être
davantage informés c'est le cas en tout
cas en France de ce qui se passe mais
pas forcément d'avoir un débat public
sur cette question
après la France livre du matériel
parfaitement
en tout cas j'allais dire combat de
proven en tout cas mais en suffisant en
quantité insuffisante parce que elle n'a
pas les moyens d'en livrer plus enfin
genre quand on livre des lance-roquettes
unitaires à l'Ukraine il faut savoir
quand même que la totalité de l'armée
française dispose de notre sur le papier
en tout cas de 12 lance-roquettes
unitaires et que au final il y en a
moins que ça qui sont opérationnels donc
on peut pas en livrer davantage sur les
chars c'est pareil je parlais de 222
peut-être 160 qui fonctionne je ne sais
pas exactement mais donc on peut pas non
plus en livrer les quantités
astronomiques et justement on va voir
tout ça a-t-on les moyens de livrer plus
d'armes quelles conséquences sur notre
armée vous avez travaillé sur ce sujet
vous avez publié un rapport on en parle
avec notre journaliste parlementaire
Marion Delpech
[Musique]
bonjour Marion bonjour Merci beaucoup
bonjour
parlementaires alarmon ont été récemment
consacré au stock d'armes dont dispose
la France oui effectivement il y a pas
moins de trois rapports qui ont été
rendus ces dernières semaines de venus
de l'Assemblée nationale et en réaliser
par des sénateurs dont vous Cédric
Perrin dans celui des sénateurs on fait
ainsi la liste précise de nos
équipements les plus importants la
France dispose par exemple de 222 chars
de combat 18 systèmes solaires et 253
avions de combat par ailleurs concernant
les armes françaises livrées à l'Ukraine
même si le gouvernement ne communique
pas vraiment ces chiffres on estime
qu'une trentaine de canons dont 18
Césars ont été livrés des missiles
antichard également des engins blindés
équipés de canons la Russie et l'Ukraine
on respectivement déjà perdu en un an de
conflits 1642 et 449 chars de combat 88
et 86 systèmes sol air et 69 et 56
avions de combat les parlementaires sont
très prudents sur le niveau de
préparation du pays face à une guerre de
haute intensité le rapport sénatorial en
appel ainsi à des engagements ferme de
l'État en termes de commande de
relocalisation stratégique comme par
exemple les poudres propulsives pour
renouveler des stocks existants et c'est
une demande qui a été entendue par le
gouvernement Marion oui tout à fait
Oriane hier le ministre des armées a
annoncé à nos confrères du Parisien que
la France allait bientôt relocaliser sa
production de poudre explosive pour les
obus Sébastien Lecornu a reconnu que
l'Ukraine allait connaître des besoins
important dans les semaines et mois à
venir et c'est l'héritier de la Société
Nationale des poudres et explosifs
l'entreprise publique eureenko qui va
investir 60 millions d'euros dont 50
seront autant financés sur son site de
Bergerac comment accueillez-vous cette
annonce Cédric Perrin bien et vous venez
de rappeler que c'était un rapport
parlementaire qui est sorti le 9 février
dernier qui demande justement à ce que
on travaille à la
relocalisation en France de la
fabrication des poudres puisque je
rappelle que pour le moment nous les
achetons intégralement à l'étranger et
que dans des périodes comme celle que
nous vivons aujourd'hui les pays
étrangers ont tendance à plutôt
favoriser leur propre industrie avant de
livrer les entreprises les industrie
étrangère donc moi je pense que c'est
une excellente nouvelle qu'il faudrait
la suivre également sur peut-être
d'autres productions de matériel
militaire
on a abandonné quasiment
dépend entier de notre industrie
militaire depuis 20-30 années parce que
on considérait qu'un certain nombre de
produits n'étaient pas souverains et que
on pouvait parfaitement aller les
acheter à l'étranger parce que je ne
cesse de rappeler à la commission c'est
que derrière c'est c'est ces industries
il y a quand même des hommes et des
femmes ou des femmes et des hommes et
donc il y a des emplois et il y a
l'aspect souverain mais il y a aussi
l'aspect industriel l'aspect humain
l'aspect expertise l'aspect expérience
et tout ça c'est évidemment fondamental
ne jetons pas le bébé avec on a des
entreprises extrêmement compétitives
extrêmement
on a des entreprises qui fabriquent du
matériel lourd on a Nexter qui
fabriquant aujourd'hui griffon le jaguar
le serval qui fabrique le César qui
fabrique des munitions on a MBDA qui
fabrique des munitions de haute
technologie particulièrement
vendus dans le monde on a on a on a
Thalès qui était un des leaders mondiaux
de dans le domaine de la défense on a
Dassault qui est un exemple
extraordinaire on a Airbus on a
énormément d'entreprises et puis
derrière tout ça on a 4000 petites PME
et e ti qui constituent un tissu
industriel de l'ordre de 200 000 emplois
direct et je pense en tout cas au moins
autant indirect c'est à dire bientôt
l'équivalent de l'industrie de
l'automobile quand même qui sont des
boîtes qui fonctionnent très très bien
et qui savent faire beaucoup de choses
donc soyons soyons positifs on va
continuer à parler de ça je remercie
Marion merci Marion à tout à l'heure on
se revoit pour parler du parcours du
président ukrainien depuis le début de
la guerre exactement ce sera dans le
club merci Marion on va continuer à
parler de ce sujet avec vous Cédric per
Rin parce que c'est aussi l'objet de
votre rapport entre les questions de
souveraineté et puis les questions de
livraison d'armes est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
la France serait prête à faire face à un
conflit armé
je crois qu'il faut mesurer nos propos
je j'entends ce que vient de dire votre
collègue en comparant la trission de la
guerre en Ukraine avec le nombre de
matériel dont on dispose mais en fait on
peut pas vraiment présenter les choses
comme ça parce que la France est un pays
en Europe le seul pays de l'Union
européenne qui est un pays doté de
dissuasion nucléaire de l'arme nucléaire
et donc ça ça change la donne et
donc évidemment dans un conflit majeur
comme celui-là nous serions engagés mais
nous sommes engagés avec nos alliés avec
nos partenaires et donc évidemment qu'il
faut avoir une réflexion qui qui englobe
en tout cas cette coopération avec nos
partenaires européens nous n'aurions pas
évidemment si la Pologne achète des
milliers de chars et des milliers
d'avions c'est parce qu'elle imagine
avoir une grosse attrition c'est notre
cas est différent en revanche ce qui est
certain c'est qu'aujourd'hui il faut
prendre en considération le fait que
nous devons marcher sur nos deux jambes
d'un côté la dissuasion mais de l'autre
côté conventionnelle elle conventionnel
il nécessite évidemment une remontée en
puissance si demain nous devions être
appelés évidemment personne ne le
souhaite mais au titre de c'est que 5 de
l'OTAN à la solidarité en termes
d'intervention sur un pays de l'Est de
l'Europe ou autre on le ferait avec nos
alliés mais on le ferait aussi avec
notre propre matériel donc ça nécessite
évidemment qu'on ait une remontée en
puissance qu'on évidemment qu'on
travaille sur la question des munitions
c'est une question absolument
fondamentale aujourd'hui et qu'on soit
aussi capable d'être un allié exemplaire
au sein de l'OTAN un allié exemplaire
c'est un allié qui est capable d'aider
ces partenaires en apportant notamment
des munitions l'important du matériel
pour soutenir lorsqu'on n'est pas collés
comme belligérant qu'on pour soutenir un
certain nombre de de conflit et c'est le
cas aujourd'hui en Ukraine donc on a
besoin de remonter en puissance mais on
n'est pas non plus
les stocks de l'armée sont adaptés sont
suffisants alors je vais vous faire une
une
on m'a dit pendant le rapport oui oui
nos stocks sont adaptés pour le nombre
de pièces dont on dispose
voilà j'ai tout dit
qu'est-ce qu'il fait le plus défaut
aujourd'hui à l'armée
écoutez on a un vrai sujet sur la
défense solaire clairement vous avez vu
on a parlé de 18 pièces on a un sujet
sur l'artillerie on a moins de 100
pièces d'artillerie au catalogue c'est à
dire qu'en terme je vous expliquais tout
à l'heure que pour les les rues entre ce
que ce dont on dispose au catalogue
est-ce qu'il fonctionne dans ce Rocket
chagrenu pardon unitaire et dispose il y
a il y a évidemment la marche donc oui
on a on a on a une armée qui est plutôt
échantillonnée on a on n'a pas
suffisamment d'avion on n'a pas
suffisamment de de char pour pour un
conflit comme celui du crâne mais après
il faut aussi définir la stratégie qu'on
veut mettre en place et moi c'est ce que
je dis depuis le début on va voter la
LPM bientôt ici au
sénatration militaire pardon ce que je
dis clairement c'est que c'est la
stratégie qui doit faire le budget et
pas le budget qui doit faire la
stratégie parce que sinon on a une
stratégie qui contrainte et donc ce
qu'on nous attendons aujourd'hui du
gouvernement c'est qu'il nous explique
quelle est la stratégie qui veut mettre
en place pour que derrière nous nous
définissons en tout cas les moyens que
que la loi de programmation militaire va
offrir à nos armées alors le président
de la République a annoncé un budget
le 19 janvier dernier je crois de 400
milliards d'euros
pour vous
il fait je dis pas qu'il fait les choses
à l'envers mais je pense qu'il serait
plutôt urgent aujourd'hui de définir la
stratégie et ensuite de discuter du
budget qu'on va mettre derrière mais 400
milliards d'euros ça vous paraît un
quotidiens nationaux enfin les paga
façon de parler comme étant le seul
parlementaire qui ne se gargarisait pas
de cette annonce présidentielle pour une
raison assez simple c'est que je pense
que nous n'avons il y a un certain
nombre de phénomènes que nous n'avons
pas pris en compte enfin en tout cas qui
ne sont pas suffisamment de mon point de
prévoir c'est l'inflation d'abord parce
que quand vous avez un budget à 400
milliards ça vous fait une moyenne
annuelle de l'ordre de 57 58 milliards
d'euros quand vous avez une inflation à
6%, ça vous fait tout de suite déjà 3
milliards qui sont qui disparaissent or
les trois milliards c'est deux fois
l'augmentation que le budget de la
défense a subi depuis entre 2017 et 2022
donc c'est pas une paille ça on parle
pas là de de phénomène donc tout ça
c'est pas forcément pris en compte et
puis derrière tout ça
on a le l'urgente nécessitait de de
remontée en puissance donc oui c'est une
histoire de choix je mets je ne suis pas
de à dire non plus que l'augmentation
n'est pas importante elle est
considérable mais est-ce qu'elle est
suffisante je ne sais pas je pense que
pour avoir un modèle d'armée complet
c'est ce que j'ai dit il y a pas très
longtemps je pense qu'on est un peu en
de ça en deçà de ce qui serait
nécessaire
dont vous parliez où il a annoncé ce
budget Emmanuel Macron a dit que
l'objectif était d'avoir une guerre
d'avance c'est un peu plus pour vous
ça veut dire quoi je pense que surtout
ce qu'il faut c'est anticiper les
conflits futurs et être capable de d'y
répondre
la grande discussion qui qui aujourd'hui
fait ferrage c'est celle la technologie
ou de la masse on a démontré dans ce
rapport que la technologie est
fondamentale mais que la masse une fois
que le conflit est engagé et qu'on a
dans une guerre de haute intensité la
masse est importante pour pouvoir durer
c'est le problème aujourd'hui de
l'Ukraine la capacité de durer parce
qu'aujourd'hui le problème au nukraine
il est numérique c'est à dire qu'on a à
fond deux armées qui s'affrontent dont
qui sont qui sont évidemment c'est un
peu le Petit Poucet qui se bat voilà
donc aujourd'hui la difficulté de
l'armée française c'est de gagner cette
masse et de conserver cette technologie
parce que
la Russie par exemple si on prend
l'exemple de la Russie à une stratégie
qui consiste à pilonner pilonner de
manière intensive et massive l'armée
adverse avec des quantités astronomiques
de matériel on a à peu près 6000 au but
de 15 des personnes qui sont enfin qui
sont malheureusement tirés tous les
jours alors que nous on en fabrique 5000
par an donc ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on
gagne en efficacité que peut-être nous
ayons du matériel beaucoup plus efficace
pour avoir à moins en utiliser pour
tirer au but immédiatement donc voilà il
y a des discussions aujourd'hui qui sont
là et qui je pense en tout cas feront
que la loi de programmation militaire
quand elle arrivera au cela sera
absolument passionnante et nécessitera
des débats qui qui je pense en tout cas
au Sénat montreront que la majorité
sanatoriale a aussi du poids
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé en
2017 ou on nous a un peu marché dessus
et on nous a pas forcément écouté
cette fois je pense que nous aurons
notre mot à dire
le secrétaire général de l'OTAN
dit que production de munitions
occidentales est inférieure alors
consommation par le crâne est-ce qu'il
voit juste est-ce qu'il a eu raison de
le dire d'abord je vois je pense qu'il
voit mal et qu'il n'aurait jamais dû
dire ça je pense que c'est une erreur
stratégique majeure que d'avoir réalisé
ces choses là sur des choses qui peuvent
se dire entre allier entre en petits
comité mais sûrement pas sur la place
publique et il y a une Berg de ce point
de vue là effectivement fait une erreur
je pense majeure
d'autant plus que c'est quelque chose
qu'on sait pertinent
d'affirmer nos faiblesses sur la place
publique dans des périodes comme
celle-là c'est là on est un peu dans la
même dialectique que ce que vous évoquez
tout à l'heure avec l'annonce des
matériels qu'on livre à l'Ukraine est-ce
qu'on a besoin de le dire sur la place
publique je suis pas persuadé on va
continuer à parler de ce sujet puisque
je le disais c'est à la une de tous nos
quotidiens régionaux ce matin et
notamment ceux du groupe centre français
on retrouve Julien Bonnefoy
Clermont-Ferrand bonjour Julien merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
chargés des opérations spéciales au
groupe Centre France Julien et vous
revenez d'abord sur cette question dans
les territoires du groupe Centre France
que sont devenus les réfugiés
oui Oriane et ce sont d'ailleurs les
premières pages de ce dossier spécial à
retrouver également toute la journée sur
nos sites Internet et applis on y
retourné voir les réfugiés Ukrainiens
dans la quinzaine de départements que
couvrent les rédactions du groupe Centre
France beaucoup sont restés on raconte
le soulagement des moments de vie
heureux après avoir fui la guerre des
rencontres des amitiés de l'entraide des
réfugiés qui tombent de s'insérer en
France d'élever leurs enfants mais on
raconte aussi beaucoup de retours en
Ukraine c'est le cas de Natalia hébergé
dans le Puy-de-Dôme il y a un an on l'a
vu dépérir raconte sa famille d'accueil
elle ne mangeait plus elle avait des
boutons partout sur le visage elle
pesait à peine 35 kg en juillet dernier
juillet 2022 c'est le mal du pays
souvent mais c'est aussi mais c'est
aussi un sentiment de culpabilité
parfois une envie de retourner en
Ukraine pour défendre les siens face à
l'armée russe ce sont toutes ces vies
orianes à reconstruire que l'on raconte
en Auvergne dans le son de Val-de-Loire
en Bourgogne et en nouvelle-aquitaine ce
matin dans ce dossier spécial et allez
également dans ce dossier spécial Julien
un bilan militaire et comment la
géopolitique bouge avec la guerre
déclenchée par Vladimir Poutine
exactement en fait nos interlocuteurs
disent trois choses ce matin dans ce
dossier spécial d'abord de regarder plus
loin car cette guerre redistribue les
rapports de force Biden a sauté sur
l'occasion nous raconte le
géopolithologue Frédéric Ansel il a
réussi à instaurer un nouveau rapport de
force avec les Chinois qui depuis en
rabattre c'est lui qui le dit car oui le
vrai match n'est pas en Ukraine mais
dans l'Indo pacifique et le partenaire
de la Chine la Russie et le looser mais
surtout et c'est pire servant un des
premiers à avoir annoncé l'attaque russe
qui nous le dit ce matin les Ukrainiens
peuvent remporter cette guerre plus vite
qu'on ne le croit car servant est
particulièrement cinglant pour l'armée
russe de type soviétique dit-il rigide
sans sous-officier sans communication et
sans possibilité de numériser le champ
de bataille Cédric Perrin en parler il
pense même pierre servant que l'armée
ukrainienne peut déstabiliser le front
russe sans même attendre les renforts en
armements des Occidentaux et cette
résistance ukrainienne à Poutine elle
est incarnée et portée parfaitement par
voler lumière zen dont nous dressons
d'ailleurs le portrait en leader très
churchillian dans ce dossier aujourd'hui
mais l'issue de se confie elle est bien
incertaine pour l'instant et à
s'inquiétante c'est ce qu'on décrit
quand on reprend la chronologie la
stratégie et les déclarations de
Vladimir Poutine c'est encore pire
servant qui nous le dit dans cette
entretien le choix que Poutine a fait et
celui de l'escalade dans l'horreur comme
l'illustre les crimes abominable commis
par ces troupes la marche arrière ne
peut plus être enclenchée cela écarte
toute solution diplomatique il n'y aura
jamais de négociation avec Poutine fin
de citation Cédric Perrin que faire face
à Poutine aujourd'hui croyez-vous aussi
à cet escalade dans l'horreur avons-nous
été trop naïf et quelle doit être la
position de la France désormais dans cet
en deux de la guerre
écoutez je crois que pierre servant a
dit tout ce qu'il fallait dire trop
naïve je le pense mais je pense qu'il
faut aussi faire son autocritique moi je
suis à l'Assemblée parlementaire de
l'OTAN les pays baltes notamment nous
alertes depuis des années sur le risque
qu'il y a avec la Russie et depuis des
années nous leur rétorons que nous
traits est plutôt au sud et pas à l'Est
malheureusement le 24 février dernier
l'ordre mondial a été bouleversé et
l'histoire leur a donné raison
aujourd'hui
contrairement à vous je pense que il n'y
aura pas d'autres solutions que de
sortir de ce conflit par la négociation
par la diplomatie et par et par par le
dialogue parce que de toute façon la
Russie est un état de thé Poutine l'a
dit à dessin il a dit on peut pas perdre
donc il faudra quand je dis on peut pas
perdre c'est que en fait la dissuasion
nucléaire fait qu'aujourd'hui toutes les
toutes les opérations militaires qui se
succéderont feront qu'à un moment même
si la Russie même s'il a l'Ukraine
l'emporte pardon derrière la Russie
demeura un état doté un état
j'allais dire militairement présent et
qui saura se reconstruire et peut-être
reconstruire aussi sur ces erreurs donc
il faudra évidemment redy dialoguer avec
avec la Russie je parle pas de Poutine
je parle de la Russie c'est différent je
parle pas du régime de Poutine moi ce
que j'espère c'est que il y a un certain
nombre de pays qui sont aussi des pays
très puissants comme la Chine qui
pourrait je je ne sais pas si ce sera
envisageable mais en tout cas entrer
dans la dans le dialogue et essayer de
trouver les solutions de sortie c'est
vrai que vous avez vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure Biden c'est engouffré
dans la brèche et aujourd'hui la
domination la domination sur sur
l'Europe est il faut le dire quand même
particulièrement présente je parlais
tout à l'heure de l'aspect industrie de
la défense mais c'est aussi une
opération plus beaucoup plus globale
aujourd'hui
les Américains ont du gaz de schiste et
non pas de problème économiques et ceux
qui subissent les problèmes liés
notamment à l'embarque sur la Russie
c'est essentiellement les pays
occidentaux les européen donc
combien de temps cette cette guerre en
tout cas cet état de ces difficultés
seront soutenables par les pays
européens et par les opinions
européennes c'est aussi une question
qu'on doit qu'on doit pouvoir poser
parce que
les manifestations que nous subissons
aujourd'hui avec une réforme qui
peut-être n'est pas tout à fait arriver
au bon moment sur les retraites c'est
aussi des manifestations qui ont
vocations à dire que les gens n'en
peuvent plus de des augmentations
perpétuelles de tout des difficultés
économiques quotidiennes il y a pas que
les retrait derrière tout ça il y a
aussi des difficultés que les Français
subissent comme les ensembles comme
l'ensemble des pays européens donc
sortir de tout ça nécessitera évidemment
je pense des négociations de dialogues
et ce que nous devons aujourd'hui gagner
c'est la paix et c'est la guerre pour la
paix aujourd'hui c'est pas une guerre si
beaucoup Cédric Perrin merci Julien
Bonnefoy on regarde évidemment les une
du groupe Centre France on en regarde
quelques-unes celle de du Berry
républicain de l'Yonne Républicaine et
de la montagne toutes les mêmes un an de
guerre c'est le dossier spécial Ukraine
des journaux du groupe centre france
merci beaucoup Julien Bonnefoy d'avoir
été avec nous et merci Cédric Perrin
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure dans 20 minutes dans
le club des territoires on reparlera
évidemment de c'est un an de guerre en
Ukraine l'analyse de nos experts on
s'interrogera sur l'issue du conflit sur
le plan militaire et diplomatique et on
continue cette édition spéciale un an de
guerre en Ukraine avec notre prochaine
invité c'est Jean-Pierre Raffarin qui
nous rejoint